there was a great really incisive
commentary
from Sophie corkaran who's British she's
on gbtv a conservative channel in Great
Britain
she said quote Dear Americans who mock
us for mourning our beloved Queen She
dedicated her entire life to her Duty
and our country even just two days
before her death you more into man who
pointed a gun at a pregnant woman by
burning cities to the ground we are not
the same
harsh but fair
what she's saying is you're all laughing
at us because you think it is ridiculous
that we hold the queen sacred
you hold criminals as sacred
you think it's ridiculous that we have
all this Pomp and Circumstance for her
royal Majesty the queen you had Pomp and
Circumstance you had you had four
funerals that one of which was attended
by the soon to be President Joe Biden
for a criminal who resisted arrest and
died of some combination of police force
possibly of police force and a fentanyl
overdose because he had he had a toxic
level of drugs in his system
which is more ridiculous
you you think that we've got this kind
of crazy
sacred thing that we venerate and we pay
respect to
well you've got them to you're just not
aware of it and yours are much more
ridiculous
this is actually why I'm I'm uh
cautiously hopeful about King Charles
III Charles has been an object of
derision for many years by conservatives
because he says all sorts of kooky weird
environmentalist stuff and he Pals
around with Klaus Schwab and he talks
about the great reset and there are
plenty of red flags and warning signs
I'm not denying that but there was a
video that went around
it was making the rounds after Queen
Elizabeth died and it made me wonder
is Charles a little bit more
conservative than we all think it's
Charles describing
tradition the teachings of the tradition
is should not in any sense be taken to
mean that they seek as it were to repeat
the past or indeed simply to draw a
distinction between the present and the
post
theirs is not
a Nostalgia for the past but a yearning
for the sacred and if they defend the
past it is because in the pre-modern
world all civilizations were marked by
the presence of the sacred
as I understand this uh in referring to
tradition they refer to a metaphysical
reality
and to underlying principles that are
timeless
as true now as they have ever been and
will be
absolutely brilliant and and evidence
that this guy this kind of weird lib
sounding guy who rattles on about global
warming and Pals around the world
economic forum
this guy gets conservatism better than
probably 70 percent of American
conservatives or more
because he's saying and certainly better
than all the libs do he's saying
traditionalism you know conservatism is
not about a Nostalgia for the past
Nostalgia is history after a few drinks
okay when when we make an idol out of
the past we're we're really being
saccharine and sentimental the past was
not nearly as great as we all like to
imagine we sometimes think that our
childhood was the greatest period in all
of human history we think that because
we were little kids and we didn't have
any responsibilities and we had the
comfort and of our parents and and so no
it's not just about this nostalgic
hearing for the past
it is a longing for the sacred it's a
longing not for Dusty old things it's a
longing for things that are timeless
that are ageless ideals that the
tradition is not some dusty old thing
it's it's the most vibrant thing in the
world because it's that which has
endured through so many years and
decades and centuries in Millennia even
into the present that it's those truths
and institutions
that the libs are attacking and trying
to destroy it's those sacred things
that they are desecrating
and and and that is what keeps
conservatives up at night I'm glad you
like that clip now here's what I need
here's what I'm begging for I need you
to ring the bell and subscribe get all
the notifications for this show
hopefully get around some of the
algorithmic issues that our overlords
are uh are inflicting upon us and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]